ciao allora erano due le torture nei
quali gli ex mi sottoponevo una era
quella che consisteva nello scoraggiare
a letto sotto le lenzuola per poi in
trappola amici sotto in modo che io sono
classi con la sua puzza
la seconda invece consisteva nel ravanas
il buco del corpo per poi passare le
dita unitel sotto al naso
che schifo casperia ciao a tutti
bentornate una nuova puntata di vita
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi è
torture subite dagli altri questo però
mi è stato suggerito da un pochino di
persone non so veramente chi citare chi
ringraziare
però di una cosa sono sempre stato
sicuro ossia chi sarebbe stato l'ospite
di questa puntata nei meravigliosi
studios da casa mia infatti ho deciso di
ospitare un mio carissimo amico
torturato dalla vita da chiunque
ed è per questo che vi presento thomas
salvarlo buonasera anzi buongiorno
buonanotte ammazza vedi il tuo arrivo ha
riequilibrato il mio viso scusa il
disturbo a quest'ora a casa tardi mia
madre prima mi ha allenato il presidente
ha tagliato ha fatto a pezzi il vestito
che mi ero comprata con i miei soldi non
mi ha detto niente io sono venuto a
scoprire perché mi sono ritrovata questo
vestito con l'etichetta ancora attaccata
completamente tagliato a mille
pezzettini all'interno del cesso della
mia camera in bella vista
la madre del genio del male io l'adoro e
aspetta per un altro m2 leo renata cosa
più unica ha perso l'uso della coppa
italia la rottura di mastella perché ci
puoi parlare oppure una volta mio
fratello
che non studiava all'università tornata
a casa lo trova per l'ennesima volta
davanti alla playstation gli strappa la
playstation dal muro con tutti i fili da
degli usa the capital ha sbattuta per
terra ci è saltata sopra urlando una
pazza ma la mia domanda è i ragazzi che
subiscono queste violenze psicologiche a
parte i genitori da grandi niente un
serial killer ossidando proprio al
tunnel della droga diventano come me
forse probabilmente ma quindi tutti e
due rosa che il discorso dei genitori
passivi aggressivi non lo capisco che
mia mamma è buonissima si è come punisco
il mio fidanzato
questa mi piace allora io le fidanzate
ultimamente lo forniscono un modo strano
ovvero piazza la maglietta tira fuori le
tette visto avevano vinto in contante la
prenda appoggiare colpi duri lo soffre e
mi diceva cosa fareste se io ti prende
ti attesi in lana in faccia dopo non lo
so si consiglia famiglie un ottimo
spoglio nei dehors aprile a questo non è
i
ma non ci sono solo quello deve essere
fidanzato di lui di questo è un atto il
profilo ebbe a dire che lei ecco la lei
questa dal mesi così a due persone che
ti picchiano la tortura peggiore che mi
hanno fatto i miei amici è stata alla
mia laurea quando mi hanno buttato dei
civici vivi nella schiena dentro la
maghetta c'è mancato poco che ci
uccidessi tutti ma in cima jim hines
fuliggine gigi le azioni di amici credo
gli amici esatto perché i musei civici
sono alle 16 i chimici i cinici come dt
idt bracci proverai franci si può dire
nel senso non vorrei dire una
sciocchezza però ci metto la faccia e
credo che si possa dire nel senso
la tortura più brutta che mi lascio al
mio fratello ho capito neanche una
parola ok prova a vedere se vai ritorno
alla tortura democratica detto la
tortura di kimi si chiamano ma una
mattina dell'estate con pistole tappo
che nei acqua disco ma alla fine la
caccia così muore o a una vongola come
animale domestico dolcissima mai un
animale in casa che la singola o
comunque arrivi in un acquario e ogni
tanto mi viene ad est a partire poi
ritorni sotto bellissima ragazza tra
l'altro si intanto ciao sono qui con la
via con collina che chiama comunque
allora io ho un particolare tipo di
proprietà ma da quando sono piccola se
le persone mi stringono la caviglia mi
sento morire come se qualcuno di
stracciasse nel collo insomma quindi lo
sai che io abbiamo quand'ero piccolo una
tortura che i diavoli orecchie nomi
potito che alle orecchie diventava una
belva ma perché non lo so cioè fare
questo esame uccide ti fa male è
semplice anche se la cattiva realtà
cartilagine superare alle orecchie
abbastanza ma come sei volgare di questo
big lato quindi ci possiamo scatenate si
contraggono sempre con gran classe
la rete è il pozzo di san patrizio
quando mio fratello aveva circa 12 anni
avevo due di lui aveva appena cominciato
a gattonare io mi divertivo a togliere
le mani
le braccia in alto momento ea fargli
battere delle testate per terra ma
perché non si fa ragazzi avevo un attimo
parlare di una tortura che ho fatto io e
la mia famiglia siamo una famiglia
abbastanza particolare nel senso che mio
nonno il carnevale delle figlie
lui l'ha sempre concepito come halloween
nato a calcio è mia mamma 8 anni era
vestita da boia e lui ha fatto una testa
che non è una cosa che si erano gli
addams e restate arrivano questi due
ragazzini e quello che noi pensiamo e
divertiamoci facciamo qualcosa e
divertente fingere una possessione
demoniaca mio fratello kg a chiedertelo
ragazzi loro stavano seduti sulla
poltrona ed egli aveva fatto di vedermi
qui vabbè mi sono lasciato un pochino
trascinare allora c'era mio cugino
nascosto dietro la loro portata
e poi c'era mio fratello nascosto
dall'altra parte con tutto l'alluminio
in faccia ha messo in modo che facesse
una faccia tipo di alluminio precedere
che a un certo punto noi evochiamo
questo demone esce fuori tenendosi la
faccia tipo impazzendo
e a un certo punto favori e dagli etero
mio cugino spingere in avanti la la
poltrona come se il potere
volevamo sentire loro sono morti e
quella l'istat un'estate in cui
spaventano tutti avevamo fatto pure un
mostro per cui il mio fratello ci
mettevamo una traccia degli altri
mettevi il vestito a quello sopra che
copriva tutto anche uno sotto avevi un
uomo di ovviamente messa bella questa è
michael bay che non aspettano un bambino
di tre anni venerazione odioso mio dio
allora fatto odioso nettamente gli altri
non se lo meritavano proprio come veri
nina infatti era stato divertentissimo
sì ciao guglielmo chang all'ospite la
top la più grande è quella che sto
subendo fino ad oggi ha 26 anni ed e mia
sorella che suona che
scherzi a parte io ho avuto un periodo
in cui mi sentivo latte della bestia
cioè i miei vicini qua anna ti sentivi
nel senso che pensavo che tu ti abitui
la meglio e ti senti la bella ma il
cartone della disney infatti per ora
gradevole in pratica le avevamo una
bambola che assomigliava a ciò che
infatti ha mai capelli rossi per le moto
chiaro insomma era molto inquietante
infatti messo neppure turkana tanta
paura di questa bambola un giorno mentre
dormiva ho deciso di mettere questa
bambola su un passeggino insieme alla
bambola avevo messo sempre sul
passeggino una torcia che illuminava la
bambola da sotto che mi solo la faccia e
anche il telefono con la canzone
dell'esorcista prevede la vita ciao
davide toccarla chi avete storto gli
occhi grazie alla spaventosa non è una
cosa sì l'anno truccata per forza ma poi
è un occhio chiuso uno stuzzicadenti ha
incastrato in almeno mezzo rotto mamma
mia ragazzi sono questo si direbbe pt
primo di libero che lasciano la tortura
più brutta che ho subito è stata
sicuramente quella subita dal mio
fratello maggiore ovviamente che mi
scoreggia in faccia e mi chiude la testa
tra due cuscini tenendomi ferma in modo
che io possa annusare tutto per bene il
suo odore
cioè lui cosa fa il salto è che gli
rende la testa poi nel tanto con lui si
tuffa prospettiva si sa dove si gira
l'acchiappa tra noi visto che l'aveva la
blocca così
e lei soffoca grido è prendere cuscini
prenderci una pausa mano e sapevo che è
tappo ai lati se ne andava lasciata
d'agata che ne so sul divano sul letto
lui la fa e poi si gira che gli adam rai
la tappa è bravo bravo da una tortura
che sono costrette a subire e mia mamma
che mi chiama anzi urla in ogni dove i
droni per chiamarmi che sta appunto per
dromedario in quanto io ho un problema
alla schiena che mi possa essere
leggermente gobba e lei utilizza questa
sua delicatezza
stare dritta non è vero non ci posso
credere lei in commenta con almeno
grazie a lei mi ricordo che il
dromedario una gobba il cammello nel 2t
prego cioè non ho però magari in maniera
simpatica non lo so non commento perchè
queste cose sono veramente crudeltà
gratuite sui difetti fisici non ci
scherza ma tu scappa di casa tesoro mio
libera.tv prediligo madre tutte dallo
zio era solito farmi uno scherzo
ovviamente quando mi alzavo in bagno per
andare a giocare con i miei contini cose
che fanno i bambini durante i prezzi di
famiglia lui metteva un uomo sulla mia
sedia e diceva a tutti quanti che le odi
posto nuovo movimento ea scrive lari per
chi non capisco questa insegna ve lo
voglio fare molto carina che dal cubo di
mina tv si voglia di non mettersi la
cintura in macchina per ovviare a questo
problema mio padre o giorno decide di
fusione dice anche tu puoi ben capire
quali tra umani è stato inflitto
allegati quattro anni sono un po perché
sono perplesso
innanzitutto come affitto l'incessante
come è chiaro che i bambini a quel punto
i miei nipoti quando cielo li leggo del
controller o volontà andrebbero file
nola la presenza di cinque minuti arriva
sulle scene quindi chiudiamo lampione
lavora veramente effetto costanzo
effetto che volevo dire una cosa di miti
ringrazio tanto per avermi invitato che
rinvii me lo aspettavo e ti dico solo
una cosa che tra un po ci mancava che vi
dai pure kebabaro dove abbiamo lasciato
al caso sono comunque ragazzi grazie
mille per aver guardato questo video
come sempre alla fine vi chiedo se
questo video ha fatto venire delle idee
di suggerirmi qua sotto non lo so degli
eventuali temi per le prossime puntate
vita buttata mettete dei light per farmi
capire quali sono quelli che vi
piacciono di più in modo da farli tipo
entrare in graduatoria come le
professoresse fatemi sapere quali sono
state le torture che voi avete subito
dagli altri e soprattutto ci vediamo il
prossimo giovedì ciao ciao